okay hello everyone welcome to another
wolf language design review
part of our incremental language
development uh series and
uh looks like we have several topics for
today
yeah so that's true yeah the first
section here is basically a list of
functions that we've identified that we
are hoping to get done for the next
release cycle and I wanted to hopefully
briefly touch on each of them just a
little bit because it's been a while
since we've discussed some of them and
make sure the design is largely squared
away
um
so this is something we talked about not
terribly long ago but the idea is rather
than having we have things like URL
encode URL decode capitalize which are
fairly specialized
there are a number of things we've
looked at that deal with somewhat
similar but maybe slightly more esoteric
I agree I think this is good I think we
should also support capitalize and other
such things which have their own special
functions
within this
um what is the way of doing inverse
so
this is
I mean you know in other words one way
to think about this is like translation
like language translation where you say
you know German Arrow English English
Arrow French type thing and
you know I mean I could imagine we have
sluggified Arrow
something you know Arrow camel cased
um
is that realistic or is that not is that
not unique enough to be able to do that
[Music]
um
most of these are reasonably invertible
so it would not be
super prohibitive to do that we may have
some lossy operations you know if you
have text that has hyphens in it to
begin with once you slugify it you don't
know that those were pre-existing but
they probably would be processed out and
but that's like saying you don't know
it's French and you're going to
translate it and if you by default it
assumes you know in our case here by
default it assumes it's ordinary text
that hasn't been cameled or anything
like that
if you put in a camel then you're gonna
get out a lizard or something you know I
mean yeah
yeah if it's garbage input and you say
it's something else then you might get a
weird result but that's on you but in
particular if you say you give an input
that is camel cased and you say snake
cases it's not going to do it it's just
going to take that and make it just to
return the camel case thing but if you
say camel case Arrow snake case then it
could do it yeah
yeah well is that I mean
is that really the design we want I mean
it seems to me like if
I think maybe there's too much
I don't know maybe it's too ambiguous
but it just seems to me like
I don't think we can detect I don't
think we can vote or detect it I'd be
surprised
I mean and there's to me
I mean you're asking is there an
automatic case that we can Auto detect
maybe maybe we shouldn't I mean we need
a name for the plain text maybe there's
just plain text
okay and then and then some of these
things like sluggified you're probably a
sluggified right as a brother yeah as
opposed to sluggify
which is um you know because these other
ones like camel cases is arguably a noun
yeah
URL encode URL decoder a little
different but those are well URL encoded
yeah like it's you're uncoded
capitalized
I mean we could accept as input the non
past possible form hmm
yeah and there are potentially um you
know like sluggify is also sometimes
called Kebab case so we can have
alternative no sure I think so
one you know and right so one of the
functions that Alpha has is lowercase D
camel right so if you take something in
camel case and you and you turn it back
into ordinary
text and I
wonder so do we need that or do we need
like a normal or something to to undo
these
well I think we're going to say
lowercase
CAP Lower camel case Arrow plane
it's not lower camel case Arrow plane
it's
it's camel case airplane right lowercase
D camel
take rather than just sticking in spaces
will take the spaces and also
decapitalize the initial letters okay
fine but but then okay so look I don't
understand that case but I mean
basically what one should be able to say
you know snake case
Arrow camel case
so we could say snake case that we could
say for example here might be a really
good one URL encoded
Arrow camel case I want to take
something machine readable and make it
human readable yep
I really wonder how useful that that
would be but well I mean it's I don't
know whether that particular one is the
right one but I mean I think
um
taking I mean there are plenty of things
like taking our function names
which are camel cased and putting them
with dashes in between that's something
that's quite useful for putting you know
making websites that have are easy to
find and things like this
this is a nice function
all right so do you want to say more
about this right now idle case would
probably be a useful one too yeah title
case of the variance that we have in
capitalize would naturally go here yes
and people might find them more easily
here too now once we've got a decent
number of them people are just going to
be the go-to function for this
but it's good to have capitalized as
well because
no
that's a that's an idea that one thinks
of so to speak
okay any more to say about this function
yeah I don't see any immediate issues
with the the arrow syntax so I'll use
that as the initial knot this kind of
feeds in nicely to at least part of
generate password
um so in looking at this there's
basically two main schemas for
generating passwords one is generating
effectively random passwords that are
you know have high entropy but are
generally not memorable and the second
is to generate memorable passwords which
have some similar schema but are
designed to be memorable for people so
you know
and in general they have similar
parameters uh so like here's a
screenshot of an interface for
generating memorable passwords where you
basically have bits you can turn on and
off and then you can theoretically also
customize padding characters or
uh separator characters or how many
words you want or how long the words
should be look most of the time the real
use case here is I just want to make up
a random password and put it in my
password manager
and
you know
all these details about include letters
include numbers whatever
honestly there's a default which just
says just give me a freaking password
that's reasonably secure
and that's what that should do
right
um and you know the password that
satisfies whatever the current computer
security recommendations are for a
secure password
okay I I think that will be the case
that people use 99 of the time
now
I think it would be the case it might be
the case
um
I I kind of don't agree because lots of
of websites have different restrictions
on on their passwords
who has an upper level
it's not upper limits it's you know you
must include special characters you
can't include special characters who has
the new count include special characters
uh
there will be requirements that you have
to have some special characters and
it'll be exactly
special characters
for different people can make a point
about this I'm pretty sure okay
let's ask somebody who deals with
computer security stuff which is not
what we have in this meeting
but it is my contention that you know I
know like a you know random password
manager that I use right has a generated
password type thing and it has
parameters in it but I'm pretty certain
I've never had a case where when it
generates a random password that that
won't work in the website I'm trying to
enter it into
I've definitely run into the opposite
but okay what in what situation
um I mean random
consumer websites will have things like
you know saying you know special
characters not allowed or you must
really have two special characters
really generally a poor really security
practice Yeah like you can't have white
there is no standard character or they
might be worried about code injections
so certain things you know
I think these are things of the past but
maybe I'm wrong they shouldn't be but
well maybe there's you know there's
websites that were set up 300 years ago
that you know before anybody had even
invented electricity or whatever
um that that uh you know that have that
stuff
there was some Bill I was trying to pay
the username had to be maximum 48
characters but the password had to be
maximum 16 characters just made me want
to tear my hair out that's incredibly
stupid somebody just got it wrong they
had some Cut Rate programmer somewhere
who just got the numbers switched around
um
although I mean if if the point is to
just copy this and paste it into your
password manager
who would ever use this rather than just
click the button in their password
manager
um well you might not be using you might
be using our keychain management system
right remember what this needs to flow
nicely
into a crypto stuff and our keychain
management stuff
I I mean I admit that I have not used
um
uh
I haven't used our keychain stuff of
other people here used it
I mean it was built with great effort
and I I really meant to use it and I
just haven't had a chance to do it
yeah system credential you know how this
works
it well poorly
um what do you mean by experimental
isn't it yeah why do you think it looks
poorly yeah well it doesn't work on the
Bibles machines and I I have no idea why
um aren't they Linux machines yeah so
well so it's just the system credential
system credential isn't uh isn't a Mac
specific no I know that but it's
implemented differently on different
machines different machine type
it's identifies with the system keychain
or it's implemented but some other thing
whose name I now forget on Linux
uh well first of all its Implement is
set up to use the operating system
keychain
right well I mean it works on my home
Linux machine but it doesn't work on the
Bibles machines I.E poorly
um so so Guys somebody should whoever's
doing project management here Avery
could you chase that particular suit to
figure out why that's
sounds like that's assisted minutes to a
culmination system and development issue
I I don't think that's a system an issue
um okay well let's find out
find out somebody knows what's special
about those machines so let's start with
that and find out why it doesn't work on
those machines
um okay and I mean it could be it could
be a system an issue but they disabled
the service that is running the keychain
no because it's filed back but whatever
okay I I doubt it I I'm I'm willing to
bet that it's not a system an issue okay
fine whatever um but but but and you
know even if they did then you know you
should get an error message about this
service I understand let's stop
complaining about that particular issue
we'll get that well but you're the one
who's making such a big deal of it no
but I'm saying I'm saying that look the
system credential thing is a place where
you might seriously use generate
password do we agree
yes
um maybe
it should be right here right here this
is a typical case where we've got you
know system credential where I've got
something where I'm going to type in a
freaking password
right
and you could just say generate password
is the right hand side of password right
which means I I don't even have to worry
it's it's in there I don't even see it
it's just put in there it just works I
hope
yeah and I guess my my point with the
options or the parameters here is that
we obviously want a good default that
follows good modern security practices I
think there is Merit to having the
ability to disable numbers or symbols or
right so may I make a suggestion let's
let's do this the same way we do it for
for the cryptography stuff so if I say
um generate
uh asymmetric keypad yeah oh God do you
know this is such a stupid bug when I
hit return at this point it should go to
the autocomplete it should not go to the
partial completion I've said this like a
hundred times
disagree I disagree and I think most
people disagree with you on that point
well there's something different that
happens in search engines and other
websites that just seems to just work so
let's figure out what that is and let's
see why we're not doing it
okay
okay so here
the way this works which I think is
pretty good is it has a default and then
it has an association that you can give
I think if I remember correctly that is
some very fancy Association that has you
know that allows you to specify all
sorts of um yeah see an electric curve
with yeah okay
well that's the method option but I
think I think you can specify
I'm not sure exactly how this works but
I think this is the this is the pattern
to follow
okay
yeah that gives us flexibility where
yeah and I think that's the thing to do
because because I can imagine a case
where there's some wacky you know where
toxic decides or something you know some
future service decides that they're
going to do something cute or every
password has to have a pig Latin phrase
in it or something and um you know and
then we're we'll eventually want to
support that just like what we have
noticed with blockchains and with
cryptography is there's a look you see
we have keys suitable for Bitcoin
ethereum Etc so what we could imagine
here would generate password is
something if it's needed you know Keys
suitable for blah
makes sense yeah
or if they're named password standards
could use them exactly right so we
should find out about those things but I
think this is the you know and again
just like generating asymmetric keypad
the default case I mean I'm sure if I
run this
um
why don't that autocomplete
that should auto complete that's a bug
that's a favorite thing to report
okay got it
yes yep yep I got it
okay
so I mean this will be a thing suitable
for ethereum this is exactly the kind of
way we want to do it for passwords that
you're going to generate a password that
is suitable for
see the different different sizes
private key size public key size Etc
they're different
makes sense
yep makes sense to me
okay
let us proceed I mean probably you want
something which is just generate
password and then just a number here
which just says how long the password is
yeah as a simple case of a simple
default case you know that's a kind of a
ramp down from the association yeah and
then potentially you could say you want
n passwords of length blah but that's
maybe oh
it's something generally reasonable I'm
not sure that's useful
password generator and it's it's
certainly more common with memorable
passwords you know generate me five
memorable passwords and I'll pick the
one I like I see my keychain manager and
I don't like battery or staple I want
apricot be wax
okay I understand well that's an
interesting case but we could but that's
the second argument but that is
right so maybe what it looks like is
generate password memorable comma 10 or
something
or or alternatively I mean I would I
would call it words comma 10.
and that's going to be the language I
swear what's it called diceware
I never heard that term
sounds like we may need some
Alternatives but but by the way if we're
doing this Wikipedia article for it it's
like you number a bunch of words you
number a bunch of words from the
dictionary and roll dice was the
original thing well nice but but I mean
since we have the capability we might as
well also support languages language
settings for that
makes sense
yeah since we can easily do it
yeah we'd basically just be working at
word lists for those Executives anyway
so take word list and we we I mean
that's really all we're doing and I mean
we can be a little bit cuter because we
can probably do the noun word list
um
is what I'm saying yeah
again if we have Association for
defining parameters you can say I want
nouns or I want words of length five or
five to eight or whatever we can have
those parameters for filtering
yes but I think I I tend to think I mean
maybe I'm wrong but a lot of these
things use nouns not verbs in their
random sequences
most of the password generators I've
seen do that right well since we have
word list with nouns I mean it's really
quite simple we're basically just saying
random sample word list you know noun
comma you know 10 or something and we'll
get 10 random nouns and it's really kind
of easy eff has also put out lists of
words for this exact purpose okay
well that'll be a useful thing to have
it might even be useful for wordless to
have that
certainly will be useful in data
Repository
okay yeah we'll follow that as a oh yeah
okay related thread
yeah I see that listed here
that's a good idea right that's a good
idea to also remove
isn't it funny that crypto analysis
comes up as one of the random words
I mean also also actually the truth is
that that if somebody's put out a good
list of words that probably includes
words where the spelling is easy
like right it smells like that it's not
really a good one because it's not
fanatic relative to the other version of
fairy right
so I like that idea but I think that
idea data repository and or actual word
list
okay
actually random word should definitely
support that concept
of a of a you know a kind of easy to
know is it a recognized word type thing
so that's a thing for I don't know who
maintains random word I speak to it it's
mostly me and also Alan's group okay
yeah okay fine we have types there and
by the way I thought this had been fixed
years ago to put a small space in the
case of in that case so it doesn't look
like a a rectangle there
every another thing that's with the
documentation team I guess
got it
um
okay on to the next thing
these are two good functions we've got
to find here so let's go to the next
thing
from character name
so this is basically the inverse
operation for character name
um we looked at a wfr version of this
and specked out the idea that we would
also be able to specify what type of
character name it comes from this is
kind of just a toy version of it but
um
okay but isn't what we really want here
an interpreter
I mean in other words to have the formal
Unicode name with all the capitalization
and so on is where would you even get
that from
isn't the thing you really want the
thing where you
like an interpreter give the name of the
character you want
as a natural language
and then this gives you the character
I'm I'm confused by the use case for
this basically
I understand the use case well okay hold
on
HTML name I understand that use case
it's a common name that's going to be
like an interpreter right because I mean
what I at some point what I want to be
able to say is
you know I mean don't we have an
interpret of a character name we do have
a character interpreter
but I think that's means something
different doesn't it
um well it returns back a character
entity but you can
um
okay but then this has a from entity
good
what the hell
that's weird that's probably a bug yeah
but now if I say here
how do I even see what it is
um
where is it
where is the actual Unicode is it glyph
foreign
yeah
that's really stupid
I mean what is its Unicode value
I would have assumed there would be one
there I can yeah something has gone
wrong
but so
isn't the thing that interpreters for
unstructured natural language yeah
character name is
like basically just to look up yes I
guess that would normally be the way
that it works right
so I'm you know which is why I'm a
little bit confused because here
how distinguished like HTML name and
Tech name both are distinguishable by
their structure
yeah code as well generally
well standard name certainly is
see I think that what we could do here
I'm not even sure that that one
we could maybe do that one as a courtesy
probably it's unambiguous
standard name and long name are the same
aren't they
but common name is something quite
different yeah I think there are some
cases where standard name and long name
are different
yeah common name is the label for The
Entity
formatting yeah I know I know
okay but I don't think we should support
that here
I think that's an interpreter thing all
right
I think these other ones which are
canonical why don't you see that that
will work
to have you know things for which there
is a standard name
and I think the tech name
really needs to be the backslash PSI
thing and the HTML name the Ampersand
whatever thing I've got what I'm saying
yeah
because that way then it's an ambiguous
the appropriate markup
right
I'm I'm I think I missed something so
are you talking about both specifying
HTML name and including it or if it
includes then we infer that it's the
HTML name yes because there's no other
meaningful thing that could happen you
know if we see from character name
you know ampersand
Alpha whatever it is that the you know
we got that we see you know backslash
Alpha we got Tech we're not we know that
that isn't our standard name right right
if we see
you know Alpha like this we know it's a
standard name
and
perhaps as a courtesy although I'm less
you know excited about it we could
support you know things like this the
Unicode name
with its ridiculous capitalization
which will eventually go away
I'm less Keen to do that but I think
it's okay to do that
meanwhile
we should have something which is either
it's just interpreter
yeah the problem is interpreter Returns
what do we have
well I think we have no versions of
interpreter that return different kinds
of things so what we want is a version
of the character interpreter which
Returns the raw character so to speak
do you understand what I'm saying
yeah like interpreter number doesn't
return an entity
yes right
um yes I can ask I don't know offhand
but I'm sure Carla would know if there
are examples where we have
two related interpreter types that just
have different return types
I think so I might think that
oh no this is integer name is that right
what the hell is very strange
uh Avery this is for you to take a
screenshot of and figure out what note
is going on here
yep I got it looks like a horrible bug
in 13 2 which needs to be fixed
sake
what the hell is this
well whatever it is
well I mean if the question is what is
bio formats link or what is no why was
it interpreter why did it come up in
this case this is a absolutely wrong
situation
yes I'm totally crazy
oh come on I wonder if it's a bad import
call somewhere that's triggering yeah
yeah I'm sure it is but but um
why didn't this
come up with integer interpreter that's
another thing for Avery to go chase in
the search system
got it
yep I have it
crazy
if you just search for integer it's the
second result that comes up which isn't
great but at least I know but it's not
good enough yeah
um okay so the point here would be
IC
semantic integer is what we want
okay but anyway what we're going to need
is an interpreter name again this is
something Carlo would know immediately I
mean there are clearly are cases here
with held expression and active
expression where those are variant
return types
and I have to say I think it's a mistake
that
the character thing Returns the the um
uh
The Entity yeah rather than the actual
character
well it's definitely a mistake when you
can't get the actual character out of
the entity as well
that's horrifying yeah yeah we'll chase
that part with Allen okay all right fine
okay well I think we've got to put we
got a direction here
okay co-map so there are futureized
documentation Pages for comap and go map
apply
um but this is what used to be head map
the idea of provide a list of functions
or a collection of functions and an
argument to apply them to
you know codemap when I see it here it
just
it
it blars category Theory
which is not a good thing
I mean not that I think there is I don't
even know if there's a thing called the
code mapping category that there might
be it sounds like category Theory
anybody have a response to that
I'm still not totally sold my name is
what I'm trying to say to me that's a
good thing
okay well that's that's a good start
category theory has some very nice names
in it very good naming
that's just a bit of a you know alien
language to most people
I feel like I actually more or less
understand it now which is good
um
I think you should say missed here and I
think you should say I think you should
list it out you know
a1a2a3 or E1 e2e3 and lists here
and say so you used expert to follow map
which this would support arbitrary
Expressions I know I know
well I was thinking maybe an
introductory note
that's like completely spells out the
list case
I would think that was a good thing yes
because this is an obscure function to
most people I mean
Matt was an obscale function when we
introduced it 35 years ago but it isn't
obscure anymore
actually come up is a pretty decent name
given what it does
this is an awkward Construction
because expert is an expression I mean I
think we should say
uh yeah using X
you know
um
well I would call that first thing F
list or some such other thing
or F expression or something like that
or FS or something but F's
I think experts really obscure there
like F's comma expert
you can say x is the second place
I would say the clearest thing is what
you said at the beginning having a list
and then we explain that this works for
more General cases
yeah no it says F1 F2 F3 blah blah blah
exactly
then it's understandable
yeah
apply and
make sure that also makes sense there
I mean so so that would be so this would
say
um
gives
you know
F1 of X F2 of X blah blah blah and it's
really pretty clear what it does
now commap apply
of expert here
so the X
is absolutely horrifying you say x there
because that's that's where things are
going to get funky I mean I completely
agree you could say either G of G of X
here
and then say and then show that this
goes F1 F2 F3
no because it doesn't get slowly next
there could be many things there so we
can just say Expo and then here
um
you know we could say F at at
F1 attack Expo possibly F2 at at X bar
possibly so if if we do this can this be
an additional usage message before
before the ones yes that's here okay
that's fine but you've got to rename the
thing you've got to call it an expert or
something like that or F list or
something yeah or something like that
not just expert my concern is the add at
thing wouldn't work if you had something
other than a list no I understand
yeah
okay
I wouldn't use that you could say them
words the other one
I mean you could just write this out as
apply
you know F1 comma Expo why don't you do
that comma F2 blah blah blah I think the
ads no I don't think I'd have a good
idea I I don't think it's a good idea I
think that we want to actually say apply
here
this is already a complicated enough
function so this is
or alternatively we could do how does
apply how is apply documented
in words
and this the documentation was working
35 years ago
well we could say gives gives the list
you know for the list case gives the
list in which the head of Expo is
replaced by F1 F2 F3 that would be a
reasonable way to start
yep
all right I admit this function is going
to be useful and and its name is not bad
obscure
foreign
cases is something we've had kicking
around for a little while
um Danny was starting to look into this
following position largest position
smallest it's basically a way to combine
the work that position does with extract
without having to run extract explicitly
after the fact or cases after the fact
yes I agree this is a good idea
whether the return format is right I
don't know whether it should be an
association
I mean to me position cases if that
could return
of like wanting to have an index Pro an
index markup for cases right
yes it is but I mean one way to do this
would be to return the position
followed by the case
because you know the positions are
unique
foreign
like that in a function Repository
I just put them into the studio cases
yeah
seems sensible to me
I'm not sure the position
I know I think the other name was
already taken by something else yeah
repository it's very confusing yeah
I think I think a position cases was
available I would have taken it
I like this functionality I think this
is useful
because it's easy then to get keys and
values easily get you the two things you
want
sound reasonable to people so we just
promote this one
position cases more or less I mean we
have to look at the details but more or
less yes
okay
good to me
I mean wouldn't we want to do this and
see yeah whatever this one is just time
position and then extracting everything
so it'll probably be done more efficient
right well
there's no maybe maybe who knows okay
but that's we're doing design here not
the implementation
okay one advantage to the implementation
is that it would be amenable to
um using things like compile or the
newer version thereof
which you should look at whether this
can be done with a compiler it might be
possible
okay
block protected
this seems very reasonable to me
well block random
allows you to create random numbers with
a seating
by the way one thing that I'd like to
suggest
all these functions like in a random
sample and so on I find myself a million
times doing seed random random sample
blah blah
and the truth is
all I really want is a hash you know a
random sample where it is a repeatable
you know just give me some random sample
get what I'm saying
maybe do you want the seed back
well I don't know I don't care about the
getting feedback I'd be happy if this
had
what do we call it now wait is this
random seed or
yeah
it's random seeding
right random seeding
see I'd be happy
to have something like this
because I I just think it's stupid in my
code you know I say seed random I don't
block it
see what I'm saying
but really what I'm doing is I want a
repeatable random sequence
did you understand what I'm saying
do I need to repeat
yeah I don't I'm not sure what the
the best I mean random generators are
not reversible right so I think you're
asking for the impossible no I'm not
asking for that let me explain here's a
hash of the expression it's the seed
before you evaluate something like that
no it's not as complicated as any of
that it's really simple okay I'm trying
to make a picture right I got some array
plot of some lovely cellular automata
okay
I say random integer you know one comma
400. I say I want to get this picture I
want it always to be the same picture
I'm saying
yeah what's wrong with doing an explicit
seating before that it's just an ugly
piece of code
I mean I can do this but then it spews
that random seed out into the rest of my
my code
see I really just trying to locally all
I'm trying to do is I'm trying to make a
kind of random sequence where
essentially I want a named random
sequence
right where its name is that random
integer there
does that make sense to people
yeah and I agree having written some of
this code that putting the seed random
out front makes a mess of things
yeah
uh but I have no idea what you're asking
for oh for God's sake well awesome could
there just be an option to yes that's
what I'm talking about yeah I'm talking
about this would be an example of how we
could do this we just say random seeding
Arrow blah blah blah blah blah okay and
that is equivalent to block random of
random seed of blah and then under the
block random yeah but I think that you
don't even need to call the option
random seating seed would probably be
fine there's enough redundancy there
that's not relevant
it's already that option is already
named and other functions random seating
um I think there's a reason why we did
not do this
um but I would need to think about why
it was
um
well have a think because I really need
this I mean you know it's just inelegant
I mean you can do this it just kind of
looks kind of silly
right and it doesn't Block it's sloppy
because it doesn't do a block random
of course it doesn't right because you
don't know because I didn't say I didn't
tell it to right but I'm saying that the
use case that I have for this I usually
want to do a block random
are that making sense yeah it makes
sense
right I'm subject to the caveat that
maybe each I did it does have a good
result right block random takes a random
seating right so
yes I understand I could do this with
block random I just don't want all those
characters type it in you know yeah like
I just want a simple way to do it which
this is
all right so can we please look into
whether this was let's just have this
for another meeting we look into whether
there was a problem with this and if
there isn't I think we should implement
it
um now block protected
uh the issue is its name I mean
basically it wants to I see you you're
saying maybe it wants to be block
unprotect
right yeah I'm probably not unprotected
but block unprotect
actually block and protect does seem
somewhat reasonable
comments from people
okay if there are no comments I think
that's the way we should Implement well
Stephen give people an opportunity to
think okay all right fine
um
I mean my initial
um
right I mean I think block to me block
protected makes more sense right block
random
um
what what are the block things we have
um
right
um
X I think I set that up the one the
function repository so it works either
way so if it's unprotected going into
the block they make sure it's
unprotected going out as well
so it just it just
preserves the protected attribute
whether or not it's there
why would it ever make it protect I mean
you're saying if it needs to unprotect
it will unprotect but only temporarily
if it doesn't need to unprotect it won't
it doesn't do anything it just does
whatever you know is inside the body of
the block correct
yeah I think the way I said it it was a
long time ago I wrote this one the way I
set it up where it's just locally
scoping the protected attribute in that
block
and it's just restoring it afterwards
regardless of what happened I get it I
guess I understand but I mean the only
functional case there
Isis
did protect it would it would it would
blow away the protection that you put
within that block yeah I don't know any
real use cases for that I'm not sure
that's really correct
I think it's more useful to call this
block unprotect because I think
that that is the case people are going
to be thinking about is I've got this
thing that's protected I want to
temporarily unprotect it I was actually
thinking of temporary and protect
my problem with the block is that it can
have this double May
meaning of blog of
tables main block just different block
meanings
about unprotect protect
no because because it's applying it to a
piece
of code that's the point
protect is something your play to
assemble
I mean the thing that's in there is a
piece of code
I think given that we've gone down the
path of block ground and I think block
and protect makes the most sense
next up
but the right block random blocks
through Randomness so block protect
blocks protectedness I know
that's an argument
I think it's one of these things where I
think we I I don't think anybody will
know what it does if we call it block
protect because it is a detecting
but block unprotect you could argue
blocks unprotectedness so I'm saying it
they temporarily it Scopes the
unprotectedness
okay
all right
so this is a function we discussed some
time ago that would add coordinates to
an array of data I think this is useful
I I think this is I've needed this a
million times where it's something where
you've got a list of data and
you it's kind of like a junior map in
the next right
and it will understand dates and Geo
various things
we have actually discussed calling it
coordinate eyes the last time
yes
how do the general relativists here feel
about that
sorry how do the general relativists
here feel about calling it coordinate
ties
totally ridiculous I mean it seems you
know in other words it's taking
a
I think it's a sufficiently useful
function but I think calling it
something like coordinatized would be
not crazy I mean I just want to worry
about the day when we have some kind of
manifold and we're wanting to
coordinateize it and then we're oh gosh
this thing means something completely
different
um what exactly does this function do
it takes so imagine it is
you have a list and it simply Returns
the thing that you would put okay list
plot by default just assumes that
successive entries have you know
successive x coordinates right
this explicifies that
you've got the Y sub I in a list and
this will put in one comma y one two
comma y two three comma Y3
Etc
and the general case of that it is
definitely a function I I mean
what is the shape here why does it need
a shape
well so we take the data the shape it
specifies like the ranges of coordinates
so you don't have to specify the access
fully you can say from 0 to
to 10 in steps of 2.
I understand but so that okay hold on
so one case says it's got natural
coordinates that are based on its
uh
you know it's part numbers right yep
and the other case is you are
redistributing the coordinates by
rescaling them
numerically rescaling them should that
be a data range option
well that would be closer to what it is
but also we have several functions that
do this now I mean like an axis does
this as well
does some kind of rescaling like this I
think we need to look at how that
rescaling really works
what does yeah I'm not sure what to make
of the second input so I've now decoded
the first input but what is the 149050
supposed to do
that would return 25 0 1 25 4 59 right
so in other words it's taking the
the the coordinate axis the x
coordinates and it's saying the range of
x coordinates is zero to fifty right
now these things are going to be evenly
spaced subdividing the 0-50 interval
right
so and this is that because it's in
comma rather than an arrow or is it
inferring it from the fact that it's
oh that's a two argument form never mind
right absolutely so the first argument
okay so so that's why you're calling
that the shape
right right so in the first yeah because
it could be a two-dimensional explicit
and then plus it uh one to length
is one comma length of first thing but
also the other question
is this this could be a two-dimensional
the first array could be a
two-dimensional array and you could end
up with something where you want it to
have you know the list you want to
inject
at the lowest level of the array uh you
know attachment actually you could want
it both ways around couldn't you no no
you're only ones at the lowest level it
only makes sense right so the first
array can be any any depth and the
second it's a bounce the specification
actually the first pair could be numbers
the second of dates
Etc
and it will insert the corresponding
object at that position
yes
but at the position at the lowest
position if the if the fingers of depth
D if the initial thing is of depth D it
will insert it at the Deep level
yes
well I like this function I think it's
going to take a few more minutes I just
want to you know because I'm a little
bit impatient to see these other ones
and then we have to go that's just this
this function seems good and I think
coordinates does is the right thing and
I think we should just get more detail
about it
so this is a small thing from the times
where we're working with per functions
fault pair Etc
this is gonna write my my brain hurt we
let's
go this is for yeah I mean this is very
related to coordinate eyes
yes yes in a sense
because it's the leaf operation of
coordinate eyes I think
maybe no not quite
yes we'll send application for function
and then around the form so this is
something that has been requested for
for around which is controlling like
confidence levels and and so we have two
two possible open paths here one is to
insert that information in a run itself
and the other one is to follow quantity
and have a form function that I think we
should have a form because I think the
most common case is you've got a whole
bunch of data you've got some data table
if it's only one thing you're trying to
do it with then just put the around form
around the one thing it's easy enough to
do but the fact that you can do it
around a bunch of things is really
useful
the
uh
okay this we're not really going to look
at I'm just curious what's in it
yeah these are all pretty damn
complicated
well some of them we can take up
persistent Expressions we probably have
that one
yeah I wasn't sure if that corresponded
to things like
this value yeah I think so yeah okay
this one talking of a round form this
one here is one that I really want
really want this I'm so fed up with when
I you know having to type in
you know that the canonic slaughtering
is annoying enough in itself but the
fact that you know every time if I have
minus X plus one I don't want to see
that I want to see one minus X I can get
that in traditional form but it's just
super annoying and I think having more
control over our polynomial and similar
simple math formatting using some kind
of Bank switching mechanism would be a
really good idea
for what it's worth
right well these are these are all kinds
of um
uh
yeah
this is interesting and um
yeah a lot of good stuff there
yeah we've got a lot of things here too
all right lots of fascinating stuff
coming in the future
um I mean that's yeah I think let's
let's wrap it up here let's unless if we
want to um
um
again next week so we'll talk about some
more design heavy
stuff as well I think coordinate eyes
I mean
the only thing is
bothering me here
you know it's possible that this thing
here could be
um
that we could do this that we could have
something like that
is bothering me that it's the third
argument because I think it's going to
be quite common that you
say make an association but the shape is
the Fault
is making sense
so what's
the diff
I don't understand the difference
between the previous
because I think this is going to be very
common
nice
see
I think that case is going to be
like super common
[Music]
and not as common as a list case but I
think it's going to be
um
I don't know what some of the other
cases here are what what does it look
like okay in the case the difference
here is that you may want
to have flattened xyc data or the pair
list xyc comma data so that's that's the
difference control by flattened
I understand so for example that that
makes a difference in things like
interpolation so interpolation takes the
the pair
I mean I just wonder whether instead of
that there could just be a function that
is the final processing function that is
fed
you know just like pad there it's
basically Fair the position and the the
you know
it's fed that coordinates and the thing
yes but with Associates so for example
it's wooden work right because it's not
just
exactly it's one of these FG cases yeah
so f f will be rule D would be
Association
yeah I got it
um
I'm not sure we should come back to this
yeah I I will Implement a first version
and then then we play sounds good all
right good stuff I I noticed Ethan
mentioning insert access or map counted
okay
they're both interesting names but I'm
not buying them because
axis is is just another it's a it's a
concept we just don't have here
it's a concept we could have had but we
don't have it
uh prepend might all also work like
propend coordinates because are you
putting the coordinates in front of the
numbers
yes
except you're not really pretending if
you're making an association
right yeah or if there's multiple
coordinates it's not really a prepend
but
is a perfectly nice name
I mean I'm just wondering whether the
association case is so common that it
might need its own you know
uh
I don't know if that case is so common
I think the case
the flattened versus non-flattened case
well I mean that this
see so one case is the the
superstructure of data is preserved in
the output the other case is you've just
got disembodied x y f
type things floating around in a
flattened object is that right
so in one case the data gets a new level
at the deepest level which is the pair
of the coordinate and and
sort of the position and the value and
in the in in another case is is all
flutter yeah I understand so I mean one
case is that it basically is just a
whole big list of xyfs
exactly as opposed to the structure of
the at The X Y grid structure being
preserved
so the other case I have in mind is the
same thing but X Y is wrapped in a list
oh well I I've got two different cases
for you then okay okay
because okay so let me let me show you
then so if I say array you know a
three three
okay so now
one case here is I say map
yeah okay so these are the two cases
map
indexed
you know hash two hash one
uh one two
okay so that's your one case right
that's it unflattened case right okay so
then you are imagining this case here
mm-hmm
okay but I'm imagining yet another case
which is this case well actually it
could be either case I even take this
case here oh I see concatenate of that
yes or a flattened one around it yes I
guess that's what I was controlling with
list versus array in the next line
but yes you're right this is an
independent freedom yeah
well it's in the F comma G type family
right because this is if the G is the
sub operation
the f
is um
yeah
it's very map producing
so is the is the association case if you
have like the last one you just did but
you'd have something like one one goes
to a
that's one case of it I mean look this
is an FG thing so so here for example
what we'd be doing here is we'd stay
rule instead of flattening
and um
um
that was pretty silly okay uh
and then we would say Association
now again we could have a nested
Association we have that in file system
map
right yep
so I mean there are several freedoms
here
I mean that there the f is Association
of cassinated hash
that you might actually want a
two-dimensional Association
which is yet a separate thing an
association of associations yeah
all right more thought here but good
stuff all right
time to go
see you guys soon
bye